You all remember the story.
One of the most epic, sprawling, action-packed
tales in the entire multi-verse: The saga
of Pietro Wilson and the SCP-5000 exclusion
suit.
He went through an unimaginable hell to reset
the universe and save the world from an SCP
Foundation that had seemingly lost its mind,
in an unprecedented, intentional mass containment
breach that had the stated goal of wiping
out the human race.
It was one of the most horrifying possible
timelines imaginable, and we should all be
thankful for Pietro’s struggle and sacrifice.
Or should we?
After all, there are two sides to every story,
each with its own perspective and insight.
One side of the coin was Pietro - A man willing
to do anything to return normalcy to the human
race.
On the other side was a familiar, yet wholly
unexpected face…
SCP-682.
In our original telling of the SCP-5000 odyssey,
you may have noticed passing mentions of SCP-682
here and there.
It was one of the thousands of anomalies unleashed
across the world to wreak terrible havoc on
all of us.
But what you may not have known is that SCP-682
was one of the few intelligent entities that
weren’t surprised by the sudden turn taken
by the SCP Foundation, or indeed the world
at large.
SCP-682 knew something like this was inevitable.
As soon as human beings found out about IT.
That’s right: IT.
The Entity behind all the pain and misery
of SCP-5000.
And today, thanks to the inner thoughts of
none other than SCP-682 itself, you will understand
what it’s all about, and why the SCP Foundation
took such severe action against it.
But in order to truly understand this, and
the role that SCP-682 plays in it, we need
to go back to the beginning - Two Foundation
projects with wildly different research implications,
Project PNEUMA and Project DAMMERUNG.
The first involved using cutting-edge technological
advancements to map out the human psychosphere
and understand the psychic web that connects
us all.
The latter was an attempt to explore what
happens after death, and perhaps even gain
some control over its processes.
But as is often the case when mankind dabbles
in arcane questions better left unexplored,
the SCP Foundation didn’t like the answers
they found.
The rotten fruit of Project DAMMERUNG was
SCP-2718, also known as “What Happens After
Death.”
If you’re already familiar with this one,
then there’s a good chance a chill just
went down your spine - It’s widely considered
one of the most disturbing anomalous discoveries
ever, and a member of the O5 Council who’d
already experienced it decided to submit himself
for eternal torture at the hands of SCP-106
- Just so he could avoid it.
According to SCP-2718, after death there is
no heaven, no hell, and no oblivion.
The human consciousness endures in the most
horrifying way possible: It remains bonded
to its decaying earthly body, feeling the
slow agony of rot for eternity.
Unable to speak, unable to move, unable to
scream, but fully aware as everything they
once were putrefies and withers away.
And cremation isn’t an escape here - It’s
worse.
Every molecule of ash your body is reduced
to will cry out in silence, echoing around
the empty halls of your fragmented soul forever.
With something this utterly horrifying, the
natural follow-up questions are: “Why does
this happen, and for the love of all that
is good and pure on this earth, is there any
way to stop it?”
This brings us to Project PNEUMA, the one
that’s even more closely associated with
the events of SCP-5000.
The Foundation’s attempts to map out the
human psychosphere resulted in a world-shattering
discovery: Something was living in there.
The Entity, the powerful nameless creature
we’ve been referring to as IT.
It lives in so many of our heads, watching,
waiting, and of course, feeding.
The main question here is…
On what?
Prior to the discovery that changed everything
in the world of SCP-5000, the only being that
truly knew was SCP-682 itself.
Melting away in its acid tank, bound by reinforced
restraints, hurting, bored, hating.
Imagine, for a second, what the life of SCP-682
is like.
It isn’t the most dangerous of the anomalies
out there - there are devourers of worlds
and Scarlet Kings more than happy to crush
our whole world in their claws - nor is it
the most sadistic.
A being like SCP-106 offers a far more painful
death than being quickly mauled, crushed,
or eaten by the Hard to Destroy Reptile.
And despite this, the Foundation expends countless
resources in trying to murder it on a constant
basis.
It has been burnt, melted, eaten alive, drowned,
slashed, beaten, dissected, suffocated, erased
from existence, set upon by nightmare creatures,
torn to shreds on an atomic level, and even
more terrible termination attempts than you
can possibly imagine.
We’ve made several videos on the subject,
and even we have barely scratched the surface
of the pain inflicted on SCP-682 by the SCP
Foundation.
Even in its default state, SCP-682 is constantly
submerged in hydrofluoric acid, eating away
at it forever.
Does that remind you of anything else we’ve
been talking about?
You might wonder how SCP-682 can withstand
this level of constant torture without completely
losing its mind.
To put it very simply, 682 takes a great deal
of satisfaction in knowing that what every
human has to contend with after death is far
worse than the tortures it is expected to
endure at the pathetic hands of these doomed
human fools.
It already knew what Project DAMMERUNG discovered.
It already knew what Project PNEUMA discovered.
It already knew about IT, the Entity.
It felt the constant suffering of the teeming
billions of dead in the world around it.
And it found it…
Disgusting.
An interesting choice of words, and a favorite
for SCP-682, but also for the captured SCP
Foundation Agent Samuel Ross during SCP-5000.
As we discussed briefly in our SCP-5000 coverage,
something happened that aligned the perspectives
of the SCP Foundation with that of the monstrous
reptile they take such pleasure in tormenting.
What on earth could cause the protectors of
humanity to suddenly change their tune like
this?
There are other little clues embedded in Pietro’s
terrifying SCP-5000 experience.
You may remember a strange and frightening
scene where a Foundation Field Commander went
down a row of Foundation soldiers, stabbing
each of them with a large combat knife, and
none of them reacted.
Until one did…
At which point, his comrades set upon him
like mad dogs and killed him, displaying an
uncharacteristic level of swift brutality.
And then there are the classified files from
the O5 Council and the Ethics Committee, led
by Chairman Odongo Tejani.
It goes without saying that the O5 Council
and the Ethics Committee don’t really see
eye to eye on anything, but the results of
Project PNEUMA changed that.
The following is a classified conversation
between a member of the O5 Council, namely
O5-1, and Chairman Tejani, trying to comprehend
the horror of their discovery:
My hands shake as I hold the document.
"This is confirmed?"
He nods.
"We got the report from PNEUMA staff yesterday.
It's everyone."
"Even us?"
"Even us, Tejani.
To think I'd find myself agreeing with that
damn lizard…"
"What do we do?"
"You know what we have to do.
We'll have to disseminate a cure, I think,
among personnel before we get things underway.
It'll try to stop us otherwise."
"God help us, One."
"Don't be like that, Tejani.
That's IT talking."
And one more incredibly telling quote from
a member of the SCP Foundation, picked up
by Pietro Wilson during SCP-5000:
“Once you realize you're not supposed to
feel pain, there's nothing to be afraid of
anymore.”
Is it all coming together now?
While each participant here only has a part
of the puzzle, between us all, we can see
the full picture: The Entity, IT, has inhabited
the human psychosphere for as long as we’ve
existed.
It’s a kind of metaphysical parasite, attached
to the entire human race.
And what it feeds on seems to be the after
effects of pain.
And like all efficient parasites, like a tapeworm
that induces hunger in its victims so that
it can have more food delivered unto itself,
the Entity cleverly perpetuates its own food
source.
That’s right - IT is the very cause of all
pain.
Humanity was never actually meant to feel
it.
It’s a lie we’ve told ourselves.
Well, not quite something we told ourselves,
but something IT told us.
It induced pain and tricked us all into believing
that it was a natural component of our existence.
All the while, it fed on us.
Sustained itself on the suffering that it
had seeded within our hearts and souls.
The Foundation discovered this and was horrified.
But of course, the pain it caused for the
living was only part of the equation.
Through the revelations of Project DAMMERUNG
- another thing that SCP-682 was able to know
intuitively - we can complete this puzzle
and find the terrible truth.
That truth being that IT is not only behind
the suffering we experience in life, but SCP-2718,
the even greater suffering we experience in
death.
For millennia, it has groomed humanity into
a perfect, all you can eat buffet of dismal
pain and suffering.
And until recently, they’d been so blissfully
ignorant of the horrible fate that awaited
them on the other side.
The Foundation saw only one solution to this
problem, but it certainly wasn’t a nice
one.
In order to save themselves and all of humanity
from a truly wretched eternity, they’d need
to distribute a cure among themselves - the
memetic keyphrase “Harden Your Hearts”
- and then go about exterminating every human
being still infected by IT.
Only that would presumably purge the monster
from the psychosphere forever, and grant humanity
both painless lives and restful deaths.
It was a horrible thing done for the best
of reasons.
The Cured Foundation Personnel started to
notice the horrible background noise of suffering
all around them.
They now understood how the reptile felt.
To call all of this disgusting would be a
grave understatement.
If anything could help them execute this plan
of mass mercy killing, it would be SCP-682
- A scaly savior in disguise all along.
SCP-682 was surprised to see the day arrive.
Alarms went off across the containment site.
His acid tank was drained, his restraints
unlocked.
A group of unarmed, unprotected researchers
entered the room.
He saw into their eyes: They’d changed.
They were free.
And for the first time in decades, he was
free, too.
They explained to him that they’d become
acquainted with his old enemy, the Entity,
IT.
They understood his malice, his disdain.
For once, they were suddenly joined in a shared
goal: They needed to kill them all.
They needed to purge the Entity from the psychosphere
forever.
In the words of the Foundation researchers,
they would need to exterminate everyone who
was infected, and SCP-682 would need to help.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile, relishing the
opportunity, replied, “I will do my part.”
And for a brief window of glorious time, it
was free, with no threat of recapture.
It rampaged through the world, gleefully slaughtering
scores of people.
It was in its element, taking part in the
mass extermination of the infected.
Every dead body added to the pile was another
blow struck against IT.
Soon enough, the world would be disgusting
no longer.
But of course, that’s not how this story
ended.
IT had a trump card: Pietro Wilson.
It guided him all the way, dragging him from
nightmare to nightmare, until he was eventually
able to reset the world and erase the discovery
made by Project PNEUMA.
The slate was wiped fully clean, and because
of it, we’re forever ignorant of the terrible
fate awaiting us after death, and the monster
lurking in our psychosphere that feeds off
of every morsel of suffering.
You can thank Pietro Wilson for that nasty
little gift.
Only one entity truly remembered what had
happened: SCP-682, of course.
They had their chance to save themselves,
and they ruined it.
So close, yet so far.
From that day onward, SCP-682 found the Foundation
not only disgusting, but disappointing.
Now go check out “SCP-5000 Why?
- The Full Story Compilation” and “SCP-682
- Ways SCP Foundation Tried to Kill Hard To
Destroy Reptile” for more insights into
the two epic anomalies discussed in this video!